Hello everyone and welcome to the lange
focus channel.
My name is Paul.
This is another quick video about in
linguistic concept.
This one is about something called die
glossier.
This word deblasio originated from a
Greek word meaning a state of being
bilingual.
That glossier is a situation in which a
community uses two different languages
or two significantly different varieties
of one language for different
situations.
The way it typically works is that one
dialect or language is used for casual
everyday interaction and a different
standard.
Language is used for more official
formal purposes.
The dialect or language that is used for
daily communication is typically a low
variety,
meaning that it is not formally learned
and the speakers don't formally learn
it's grammar or how to write in that
language.
It's merely learned as a spoken
The language used for more formal
situations is the high variety.
It is the language that is learned at
school formally and speakers learn how
to write in that language and they learn
the formal grammar rules of that
language.
In many cases,
the community considers this high
variety to be the pure or correct form
of the language and they want to keep it
the same and not let it change.
The low variety on the other hand is
more flexible and it's more likely to
change over time because it's not
restricted by the rules of the high
language died.
Glossier is very common around the
world.
The most commonly discussed example is
probably the Arabic language.
In every Arabic country there are
different dialects that differ in
grammar,
vocabulary,
and pronunciation from other dialects,
but also from standard Arabic.
Standard Arabic is a very codafide
language,
which is basically fixed in its rules
and doesn't really change while the
dialects are constantly evolving.
In casual speech with other locals,
Arabs exclusively used their local
dialect,
but in writing and formal speeches and a
news broadcast,
standard Arabic is used and standard
Arabic is also used as a bridge language
when communicating with speakers from
other dialects,
but really only when necessary,
only when there's some trouble
communicating.
Another example is in Italy where there
are numerous regional languages that
function as the low variety.
While standard Italian functions as the
high variety.
These regional languages are indeed
distinct languages.
Even though they are romance languages
that are related to Italian,
they are different languages,
but they're often referred to as
dialects because they are not formally
learned at school.
In recent times.
These regional languages have faded to
some degree,
but die.
Glossier is still very common in Italy.
There are lots of people who speak
original language at home or with their
close friends,
but with people who are less familiar
and informal situations,
they speak standard Italian.
Another example is the German language,
which has one high variety standard
German and many different low varieties.
Inside Germany.
A lot of the low varieties have
disappeared or are starting to fade,
but one interesting example is in
Switzerland,
in Switzerland,
die.
Glossier is almost entirely a
distinction between spoken
communication.
On the one hand and writing on the
other.
People in Switzerland don't really
accept the idea of their dialects being
a low variety,
so they tend to use their dialects in
all spoken situations,
even in formal situations and standard
German is used only for reading and
writing.
For people who grew up with no real
distinction between a low variety and
the high variety die glossier might seem
like a bizarre situation that's
difficult to wrap their head around,
but languages and the way we use them
are fascinating and full of mystery.
The concept of Dye Glossy as one that
will definitely come up in a lot of my
future videos.
So I wanted to make a quick little video
about it.
So you're familiar with the concept.
Now I want to take a moment to say thank
you to all of the people who have
supported me on Patrion so far because
that is a tremendous help to me.
It really helps me justify the huge
amount of time that I invest in this
channel.
If you find lang focus and it's video is
valuable,
the main thing that you can do to
support the channel is to make a pledge
on Patrion.
Uh,
even if it's just a small amount of one
or $2 or something that adds up and it
becomes a significant help to the
channel.
Some other people have asked me how they
can make a onetime donation rather than
making a monthly pledge on Patriarchy
and if you look at my channel page,
you will see a blue support button.
If you click on that button,
that's a way to make a onetime donation
to the channel through youtube directly.
Some of you are unable to support the
channel with money and that's okay,
but there are other ways that you can
support the channel.
You can support the channel by sharing
videos on facebook or by tweeting my
videos when they're released.
That's a big help as well and there
might be a few of you who want to do
something more significant to help out.
If that's you,
then one possibility is for you to help
out with the Geo focus channel.
If you would like to volunteer some of
your time to do some research or writing
for some of my videos on the Geo focus
channel,
then that's a possibility as well.
And if you're inexperienced editor and
you would like to do some editing work
on some of the geo focus videos,
then we can be in contact.
And discuss that as well.
It's hard to do that with the lang focus
channel because the videos are so
complex and I like to be in complete
control of them.
But for Geo focused,
it's a little bit easier.
So if you would like to support Lang
Focus and geo focus in any of those
ways,
then that would be great and I would be
very grateful.
But in the meantime,
I appreciate your viewership.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day
dish.
Oh.